the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're going to talk about
attention and you know sometimes we talk
about patients who are like very unusual
and the next lecture we will do that
we'll talk about spectacular disorders
of attention but today we're going to
talk about attention as it typically
occurs in you sitting here right now I'm
want to convince you that in addition to
slips of attention that can occur as you
get older also how you attend to the
world around you is weirder than you
think okay in a broad sense I hope to
convince you that's happening all the
time right now as you go back to your
room as you walk to the next class or
your room how you attend to what's
around you in the world is weirder than
you think okay so what is attention what
do we mean by attending to things so
William James was a psychologist at
Harvard who in many ways articulated
concepts in psychology that till this
day turn out to be sort of beautiful
ways to talk about them in an everyday
sense everybody knows what attention is
is that taking possession by the mind in
clear and vivid form of one out of what
seems like several simultaneous objects
or trains of thought it applies
withdrawal of some things in order to
deal with other so a big idea there is
we can pay attention to some things and
there's a lot of things around us and so
we have to pick where we focus our
attention a little bit like if you have
a budget if you have some money what do
you spend your money on and what do you
not spend your money on so we're going
to talk about attention it's kind of
similar to the idea of awareness what
are you aware of or what are you
conscious of and two themes across the
talk will be we often intend to more
than we realize and I'll show you very
specific and you know evidence for that
but we often attend to things less than
we realized
all the time and here's roughly to the
outline we're seeing attention you know
what you pay attention to is kind of a
gatekeeper to what you perceive and what
you know attention is very limited we
can only do process one thing at a time
and because of that we miss a lot around
us all the time there are unconscious
processes to pick up information so
sometimes things that we don't notice do
influence us and attention can be viewed
as kind of a dialogue between two things
between things in the world that capture
your attention if somebody throws a ball
at you something dramatic happens you
hear a scary sound that
captures your attention we talk about
that as bottom-up processing it's it
impinges on you it forces you to attend
to it because it's dangerous it's moving
it's unusual and then top-down things
what's your goal what do you do what are
you paying attention to what do you care
about what are you up to people call
that top-down processing so things that
are the environment drives in to your
attention because they're so dramatic
bottom-up things that you're looking for
thinking about you know are useful for
your purposes top-down
there's tremendous evidence that we
encode a very small fraction of what's
around us in a very specific way so we
go
listen estimate with me how often a day
on average since you've been about five
or six or seven and you've been allowed
to have any money in your possession at
all do you think you've held or seen a
penny okay
so we all know the horror when you're
headed in for cents and change all right
that's for pennies right there okay so
you know well we'll make an estimate
right pretend from age 5 to 20 even
handling change so maybe you've
encountered three pennies a day okay
it's reasonable okay you don't have to
be just in the right ballpark
you know there's 365 days a year skip it
15 years right just do the
multiplication you end up with about
sixteen thousand three hundred eighty
penny experiences okay all right so we
all know that as you head towards
midterms it's gonna be hard to study a
lot of stuff quickly but if somebody
said to you if you study something
approximately 17,000 times okay you
think well up that one I'm gonna get
okay
so let's ask the question there's a
Lincoln penny face to the left or the
right
is there anything above his head or
below has said is there anything on the
penny to the left or to the right and
how about the other side and how many of
you was 17 approximately 17,000 or
certainly many thousands of visual
experiences with a penny would that you
know something that means a lot to you
on the correctness of the answer to
these five fundamental questions okay
all right this is good teamwork okay all
right so let's make it multiple choice
that's better right
your rescue making me feel better
because of the foul-ups and I appreciate
that this is the actual what it looks
like okay so what do you think it means
that 17,000 exposures to a penny don't
leave in you a reasonably accurate
memory of the main things you see in a
penny how could that happen and it
happens to everybody in fact when they
do experiments you know here's people's
drawings okay
don't feel bad if you didn't know it I
mean it's psychology you know half the
people don't even think that the version
that you show them if you ask them is
plausibly correct you show them the
correct answer they go no please forgive
me yeah that can't be right okay so
here's one thing if we don't attend to
something very specifically we can see
it you know a tremendous number of times
and it leaves no impression on our mind
or no memory for of it right now why is
that in an everyday sense we don't know
in a deep science sense but what do you
think that point of it is why don't you
know what a penny looks like because
it's not important somebody said yeah
because it's close enough to see that
Browns smallish thing and you don't need
the rest of any information to hand the
money back and forth right so what you
attend to what you decide is important
makes an incredible difference and
nothing else makes up for it you know
17,000 exposures don't make up for for
what a penny looks like
you
so after you it was research at MIT that
used this method of simultaneously
processing two messages in the two ears
the shadowed message the one you're
copying and the second message the one
that you try to pick up but it's hard to
do so they asked in the ear that you're
not paying attention to what can you
pick up here's what you can pick up if a
voice is present now you just imagine
it's silence versus somebody talking
that you can notice if the voice changes
from a man to a woman okay if it changes
from a man to a woman you can pick that
up in the unattended ear the one you're
not paying attention to or if the voice
goes a person is talking also goes earn
you notice that okay here's what you
don't notice anything about the content
I mean that's what you experience it you
can switch the language of the message
you can go from English to Spanish or
Italian a person won't notice that it
changed you can change the you can also
change the weather it's typical speech
or backward nonsense speech which sounds
very weird okay you don't notice that
either so you notice a few things but
there's a lot of other things you don't
notice at all um now you may have all
had the experience of the cocktail pot
what's called a cocktail party
phenomenon do you know you do know what
that is have you ever been you know
talking with people you're at a party
you're at some events or something like
that
and somebody mentions your name you're
especially a first name of you know your
name that's what maybe you last thing
where's food and then all of a sudden
you notice a conversation around you and
it's almost hard to pay attention to the
person you're talking to because the
first one over there it's just that your
name and you wonder what they're saying
about you now here's a really
interesting paradox how did you not
notice that other conversation which you
didn't that's like the shadowing task oh
yeah I'm talking to one person there's
some hubbub over here I don't know what
they're talking about right all of a
sudden they say you're my name and I
noticed what they're talking about well
how did that happen I wasn't paying
attention to it I don't know anything
about it but my name bounced out in my
mind and drew my attention to it so it's
kind of a paradox right I'm not paying
attention but somehow I pick up my name
and so we'll talk a little bit more
about this but people have looked at
this very experimentally so here's how
they approached it
again here a sentence in one year the
man approached the bank that's the one
the repeating and in the other here they
would hear one of two different words in
the unattended ear they're not getting
much out of that they would hear the
word money or River so now the bank
could be interpreted as he went to the
bank to deposit your paycheck or you
went to the bank to have a picnic by the
river right two different meanings of
the word bank are suggested by the word
you hear in the ear that you're not
processing information and then they
people tell you well tell me what's the
sentences you just heard kind of and
people are primed to give the
interpretation of the sentence that goes
with the word that suggested the year
they weren't listening to okay so
something in their mind and brain heard
enough of that to influence what they're
interpreting and the good in the
attended ear here's another example
they're shadowing they're paying
attention and repeating aloud an essay
in one ear and in the other ear they
hear something that's like the word like
a word taxi fare and they pick words
that are spelled two different ways
homonyms so the word FA re or FA a are
now if you were typically if I asked you
to write down the word fare and spell it
correctly you might say well which one
do you want or something like that but
if I didn't tell you anything most
people would put down the word FAI are
most of the time it's a more common word
but what they found is this they
finished the experiment I shadowed one
thing they had a word like taxi fare in
the unattended ear and they said well
did you notice you got that word well if
you listen to it you remembered you
heard taxi fare but if you were shadowed
you pretty much you very rarely
remembered that you heard it say it's
not consciously available to you that
you heard it because you were so busy in
the other ear and in your mind listen to
hear but if you asked to spell the word
how often do you come up with the rare
spelling because of what you heard in
your ear it's exactly the same so part
of your mind heard that word thought
about that phrase taxi fare and when
somebody says to you write down the word
fare your mind got moved to think about
the alternative spellings the
unconscious processing of that content
has influenced you an experimentally
verifiable way so what this shows if you
go back to the cocktail party effect
which is the everyday
kind of version of this is that weirdly
enough some kinds of things that we
don't pay attention to have such a
property that in a machine like
reflexive way our mind and brain
processes it to some extent anyway and
then there's something curious that we
don't understand deeply which is somehow
if it's your name it's going like I'm
hearing my name I'm hearing my name pay
attention over here okay that's that's
like deep psychological computational
theory right and somehow you pull it out
because it's triggered your mind enough
because it's so because our names are so
important to us yeah
okay tell me against the phenomenon
where if you notice the word good so
tell me again sir comes in you what yeah
it's very much delight to the same thing
the question was you know something pops
in your head a word and then you look
back and go wait a minute I just read
that I wasn't even thinking about it or
something right I did you know somebody
said it or it's on a sign but it yes yes
that's something some experience you're
not paying much attention to tips your
mind to think a certain way and all the
sudden you're thinking that way and you
don't know what tip your mind that way
that's very similar yeah
you
so again the message here is how you
know as you're walking around in the
world there's a very few things that
you're very specifically really aware of
and many things can change on you in
these examples
okay so you know and one of the reasons
this is just a thought you know that you
could be by being selective into
attention you can focus on what you want
to focus on it's not only up you know a
weakness it's a strength so you could
pick out the message in red or you could
pick out the message in blue where you
attend this as it helps you select
information that's relevant but here's
two more works an example is I just
almost all the examples I just showed
you where from Dan Simon's who's then
really beautiful work in this way made
it very available to there so here's to
YouTube ones
you
sometimes people sometimes people have
said okay you know these are cute
laboratory things who are having people
counting but the real world is different
okay when I'm out of the classroom and
I'm out of the laboratory the real world
you kind of notice a lot more because
you're it's real people real situations
so this is one more example
that's a beautiful example of this
you
so do you think it would have worked if
the replacement person was like very
different if we wouldn't a man or a
woman or if a very tall or person versus
a person not earlier no but what does
that mean why does it work for this one
and why and why would it it means that
that means that in the person's head
they have a very rough picture of who
they're talking to is that makes sense
there's a lot of room for a replacement
not total room but a very rough picture
but it's right in front of them okay now
you've seen this thing so I won't do it
as a demonstration now where people
simply read the words the red orange
brown and that's easy because you you're
a very automatic reader if you're a
typical adult you read about 250 words a
minute okay zoom zoom zoom but if you
have the name the color of the print
when the print is contradicted by the
word right so you're reading the word
red printed in green but your job is to
say green that naming of the print when
the word is not matching the color of
the print slows people down they make
mistakes they're slower and that's
because there's a big lesson in this
it's great to get automatic at things
that's how we're skilled at things
speaking driving everything physical we
don't even think about how we walk right
the price of automaticity being really
skilled and reflexive as you lose
control right you lose control so you do
not want it you don't want to think
about what that word says but you can't
help it now let me touch one more thing
how many people think and just be honest
in your seat that hypnosis is kind of
baloney
okay all right a lot of you this is MIT
right okay
so I'm gonna tell you that I don't think
I think a lot of hypnosis the kinds of
things were you know if I learned how to
hypnotize people then they can all vote
for me or something like that right
that's not good that's doesn't work and
people who are serious about hypnosis
will tell you that hypnosis is in the
person it's not in the Hypnotizer it's
in the person it's not in the Hypnotizer
and it turns out that in ways that are
not well understood there are some
people are highly hypnotizable and some
people who are not okay so this is why I
think we were suspicious because if
we're not we're going like well they
must be faking it or pretending or
whatever
but let me let me tell you what they did
and let me see if this convinces you at
all as an experiment so they told people
sometimes to read those words where it's
confusing because you're reading the
color of the print and the word is
contradictory it slows you down okay
they told them imagine those characters
our characters in a foreign language
that you do not know with the content of
the word mess you up for the color of
the print no right because if it's a
language you don't know it's just stuff
and you can just name the okay and they
ask them to imagine that now here's what
happened for people who are low
hypnotizability you can give people
questionnaires and they're pretty good
at these kinds of measures because they
you know they're slowed down by about a
tenth of a second per word when the
information is contradictory and when
they're asked to imagine it's a foreign
language it's about the same they're low
hypnotizables you can tell them imagine
it's a print you don't know it doesn't
matter okay
here's the high hypnotizable also slow
down but when they imagine it's a print
in a foreign language they don't know
not slow down at all okay so that's
behavior that's evidence you know okay
and we don't think you can fake it
because how would you fake it but here
in case you were still worried about
that here's the brain imaging evidence
from just that people with high hypnosis
the high hypnotizable people here's what
you see here turned on is the part of
our brain areas are turned on when you
have to do the difficult task or it's
contradictory versus the easy task
okay all this area you see turned on and
the anterior cingulate and especially
which is an area that we know is
involved with things are contradictory
or paradoxical people are sorting it out
look what happens to that when these
individuals are imagining it's a foreign
text it's pretty much gone okay so I I'm
as skeptical as anybody about behavioral
claims I really am I think hypnosis is
real for some people and very powerful
for some people and for other people it
doesn't work at all I happen to be in
the low hypnotizable category okay but I
think there's I'm you know I'm as
skeptical as anybody but I think there
are people who can do remarkable things
by hypnotic suggestion but it's in them
it's not in the
a person who hypnotizes you so to speak
can help you a little bit but it's in
you whether you have that approach to
control of your thoughts or not okay so
let's go back to to a test so I'm gonna
we're gonna plug in again of us there's
two ideas that there's things that
top-down and bottom-up processes and and
different things ways that you can
attend to the world so I'm gonna ask you
to consult your own intuitions for the
following thing I'm gonna show you
things on the thing on the displays on
the monitor and your job is simply to
answer in your own mind as quickly as
you possibly can maybe just if you want
to do it aloud let's just say yes or no
aloud okay if you're going to do it as
quickly as you can
whether you see a red X sometimes
there's a red X sometimes not so ready
no okay sorry that's just that's my get
ready no great see MIT is easy sorry
get ready red X or not great ready no
okay
Thank You Ida right ready right X or not
whoa you guys are amazing now look how
many places you have to look to find it
but it didn't feel that way or did it
seem to what they call it pop out it's
just obvious it's just there okay so
imagine I gave you this this task I said
go into this room and please get a
particular book and you go into the room
and there's one book there and you
picked it up would that be easy yeah you
go into a room and you go my gosh
there's hundreds of books in this room
would that be easy now here are many
many more things to find the red X but
your mind instantly easily trivially
finds it right okay so now let's try
another version of this yes okay get
ready all right slower harder okay some
disagreement okay all right so let me
show you data under well controlled
conditions and here's the concept people
think that in many ways when we look out
in the world there's features things
like simple things shape or color those
are the two we're looking at here but in
order to combine those two no the same
thing out there has this shape and this
color to glue together features we have
to have attention and so when the
display look like this
a single feature redness helps you okay
a singer feature redness helps you don't
have to worry about the shape now you
have to worry about the shape and the
color to decide the red X worse yet
alright now you it's it's a slower
harder process and when people do this
here's exactly what they find if it's
just a feature by shape or by color and
that alone will tell you the answer you
can have one thing a few things and many
things and boom your mind instantly
discovers it instantly this is how long
it takes you to do it but if you have to
combine two things together the shape
and the color and the very same thing
combine those things you need the glue
of attention and the more things that
are out there they're more your mind has
to search search search search until it
finally finds it it has to look around
and look around and look around to find
the answer
so some kinds of things in the world we
notice without attention features we can
look everywhere at once in the display
that's how we're so fast things just pop
out and the flat slope is the
mathematically right it doesn't matter
how many things are out there boom you
get it right away other things where we
have to glue together two features
require us our attention to do the
glueing things that are together we have
to search spot spot spot see really we
don't feel the intuition of pop out and
we have a steep slope in search ok now I
need somebody from the chair
who's pretty confident in their math but
it's it's it's a little bit harder than
before but I'll tell you you don't have
to go into triple digits oh yeah I owe
you one
okay I'll come back to you if there's
one more I can't remember sir okay okay
ready you can see some numbers and I
want you to add them and tell me what
they are and I'm going to be pretty fast
is that okay desaad
achtung yes okay all right ready
yes ready' yes' ready' yes' ready'
yes now what would the letters become
sorry it's a trick
it would have been mean sir very
interesting okay now you can go all that
was a trick how reasonable is that well
let me make the argument that in order
to add the 5 and the 8 you had to look
at the letters you had to look at the
letters in the middle okay but because
your mind is not attuned to that it's as
if they weren't there almost you know
something's there right okay it's right
in front of you it doesn't seem that
hard but again if your mind is tuned to
something the other stuff gets fuzzy and
okay and you got the R right somewhere
okay let me ask one more color one more
question do you know that colors the
letters were no that's that and in fact
you don't so so thanks very much for
we're going to do that so again we just
said to bind shape and color
we need the glue of attention we're not
attending to the middle letters they
seem irrelevant you and though the right
in front of us even though we have to
walk through them in our minds eye to
move from one number to the other
they're like I don't care right boom you
move to the other side so it's not just
seeing something it's attending to
something that really matters and on top
of that you need a lot of attention if
you do glue together the shape and the
color that requires a lot of focus what
does this mean in everyday life okay and
everyday life we're probably walking
around constantly having free-floating
features around us and things we're not
paying attention to you know right now
I'm probably seeing like a yellow
computer over there and I'm seeing you
know some blue fire extinguisher sign
over there all right now why am I not
freaked out by that and why are you not
freaked out by that and why is it almost
certain because if you're not attending
to things you're constantly having
free-floating features that are
incorrect colors and shapes are just
floating around you why are we not
disturbed by that because we're not
attending it to start with okay because
it's like you didn't notice the letters
were there but then you're not bothered
they're just
refloating information you're not paying
attention to start with but that's
what's happening in your mind all the
time and these experiments demonstrated
empirically indirectly there's also
interesting temporal constraints so let
me tell you I'll describe this
experiment cuz it's too hard to cool off
here so there's a phenomenon called the
attentional blink is that what's weird
about these things right I mean why is
our minds like this and you know you can
speculate in that but it's really well
documented we attend to a small
percentage of what's around us and we
need a lot of resources to know
something well or learn something well
so here's another example what they see
where participants see is letters
presented very quickly one after the
other
e LH their job is to report any numbers
that they sees go you go boom um um um
um what were the numbers okay pretty
fast but humanly possible the
interesting question is what's the time
gap between the two numbers that you see
there's usually two numbers we'll call
this one the first one top time one is
the second one time two what's the gap
between them and how does that influence
whether you're likely to report them so
here's here's what's called the
attentional blink and a slightly scary
graph but I'll tell you okay and let me
tell you what it's like the metaphor and
then let me show you the result the
metaphor is this your mind moment to
moment to moment it's kind of like if
you you can imagine you're next to a
stream a big stream with a lot of fish
zooming by you have a fish net you dip
into the stream you'll catch something
at that moment but if a fish comes by
just as you pull the your fish net out
will you catch that one no okay so
here's what happens that here's the time
between the the computer between the
presentation if there's approximately
three numbers between them you know a
couple hundred milliseconds you're
almost a chance for the possibility of
reporting the second digit it's sort of
like the fish you can't catch because
you just took your net out except it's
not it's your mind
it's not a physical limitation so here's
what it's like so this is perfect
performance this is chance performance
if it immediately follows one number
immediately follows the next number
you're going to get both and the way to
think about that is
it's kind of like the fishnet again
right you just put it in your fishnet
you got one fish and if you're lucky
while you're kind of pulling it out the
next fish that swims in there you got
two right okay now your fish nets out
and if something else comes and
something else comes and something else
comes you're pretty bad at recognizing
it was there at all a little bit of time
comes back and you put your fish in it
back in and you're catching everything
again about a half second but how we
understand that your mind works like
that for spotting the digits that it has
to take a break there's a part of your
mind that's getting the digits and once
it's gotten a digit for the next couple
of hundred milliseconds it's not gonna
have room to pay attention to the
following digits how weird is that okay
it's because our mind has these all
these kind of limitations on what we
perceive in the environment here's
another sort of fun example of that
okay so here's it here's a task one of
these dots are going to one dot is going
to blink and your job is to keep your
eye on that dot you know when they fake
to keep your eye on the ball keep your
eye on the dot and when it stops moving
notice which is the one you've been
keeping your eye on so the first one's
gonna be easy but it'll give you a
feeling and then you'll see the answer
given to you ready so people call this
object tracking okay here we go see the
one blinking
now let's try one thing moving but even
faster
you
so now stretch let's start tracking
before things
last example
you
so here's a graph with a high level of
performance how people do so two things
matter and you might have felt that how
many you're viewing the number of
targets and under many circumstances
people seem to be able to do about three
to four but also the speed matters - you
might have felt that this both things
contribute there's a lot of interest in
this three to four limit that people
seem to have four things that they track
three to four items and there's a lot of
work at Harvard actually in
developmental psychology and related and
we just say a word about that to you
there's a thought that pretty young when
you're a kid you get to about this three
to four things that our minds naturally
contract about notice or keep a count of
about three to four things in the world
and so people who study for example a
math in the way that humans perform it
think that we have in us in our brains
approximately two systems that are
physically different and culturally
different one of them being and there's
lots of debates about this I should tell
you this but one of them being something
like accurate counting up to about three
or four and then cultures that don't
have a organized system of math the next
answer is many you've heard this right
it's like one two three maybe four and
then a lot now we don't stop counting at
four but we might if we were in a true
state of nature and we didn't have an
organized system of math and weren't
taught that and how it relates to our
language abilities so there's a lot of
debate about the exactness of this but
there's something fascinating about this
idea that our minds can have about four
units of information kept in mind kept
active that we can track and that lots
of things in the world you know reflect
that limitation including for example
exact counting and without the cultural
invention of mathematics we would count
one two three four Lots okay but there's
debates about this because exactly how
you measure it can influence how you
think about it
now can attention be trained could you
be trained to have much more attention
so in many ways we don't think you can
but in some ways you can and part of
this has come out of this ironic line of
research about things that are supposed
to be bad for us some of them might be
okay for us video games okay if you know
if you're in my general
people are going oh boy those video
games are messing up all these kids and
it's isn't that what you guys think
no okay okay so definitely at Rochester
has done a series of studies showing
that if you play certain kinds of video
games you actually do expand your
attentional capacity through practice on
those games because they make you
practice a lot so here's what she did
she took people who didn't have
experience playing video games and now
we're specifically talking about
first-person shooter video games okay
and had them do 30 hours of practice
okay and she looked at their ability to
do multiple object tracking of the kind
you just saw those dots move whizzing
around okay before and after so the
games as you know are very different but
they involve keeping tracks of lots of
things happening at once and here's what
she found that these people who you know
played 30 hours these were people who
are not gamers beforehand you know got
better at performing these tasks of
keeping track of multiple objects of all
things a group that's super interested
in that is the military and why do you
think that is okay there was just a
paper published recently if that if they
take a brain image of your brain that
can predict how good a gamer you'll
become if you haven't been a gamer
before okay these are adults okay if you
have bigger basal ganglia you'll become
a better gamer in the next week all
right if we're starting from scratch the
military is interested cuz you may know
this at an increasing amount of warfare
is video game-like which is a kind of a
haunting thing because there's real
people really being killed okay but do
you know that the whole thing with the
drones have you followed this and some
of you okay so in the US has had a lot
of success and there's a lot of debates
about the ethics of this and sending in
unmanned small airplanes into the Middle
East and using that to kill opponents
all right the person sitting in
Washington DC or somewhere else is
watching kind of like a video game when
they make that decision about whether
that's somebody to be attacked all right
so a lot of operations now are computer
based and they're kind of like a video
game at one level
they're real life hard decisions at
another level so video games you know
they're becoming more and more as you
can sense a part of real-world decisions
and controls if you play Tetris because
it doesn't require that kind of fast
thought stuff you don't get any benefit
there could be other benefits but not
this one all right so it's very it's not
just video games it's the mental
processes that are practiced in the
video games that give you certain
talents or not the abilities you didn't
have before
okay the last experiment I tell you is
this so everything we've talked about
now except a little bit about the stuff
in the second year when you're shadowing
has been about has been about this idea
that we you know don't pay you don't pay
much attention to what's around us we
don't get much in our mind compared to
what we think we would even if it's
right in front of us if you notice is
all over the place even if we've seen a
penny 17,000 times but there are some
studies that have shown something pretty
interesting also which is you know
reveal something very paradoxical about
the human mind that we can sometimes
know things without seeing or and people
call that subliminal perception so how
these experiment works as this and let
me show you one example behaviorally I'm
gonna show you one brain example so
here's what happens let's pretend you
have to read words aloud and we measure
to the millisecond how fast to read the
word if I show you this word and I show
you this word and I measure how quickly
you read the word doctor you're slower
then if you read the worse the word
nurse and then you read the word doctor
okay because these two are related and
something in your mind gets warmed up
when you see this it doesn't get warmed
up in a relevant way when you see this
where does that make sense okay you see
one word and you read the next one if
they're related semantically or
conceptually by meaning you're faster
for the second one okay that's easy it's
not too surprising the clever discovery
was this what they do is they do
something called they present to these
words under what they call masked
conditions on the computer monitor you
get something busy like a row of X's for
ten milliseconds only ten thousandth of
a second the word appears and then
there's a bunch of X's again so it's
like a flash of X's okay and people they
create situations and I'll show you this
again in a moment they create situations
where people say I'm not sure anything
was there I certainly don't know what it
is
you have to be there and you have to
convince yourself as a scientist that
you've done that all right and then they
have you read the word doctor in full
view and in these circumstances where
people cannot tell you that they saw a
word and they certainly can't tell you
what the word was
you still get faster so they don't know
that they saw church or nurse but
something in their mind picks it up and
what's picked up in the mind under the
subliminal presentation changes the
behavior when you have an overt act of
behavior reading the next word aloud so
this is you know in hardcore empirical
evidence that your mind is able to pick
up stuff at the level of meaning so
think about the paradox you think when I
read a word I see it and then I
understand its meaning right here it's
flashed in such a way that you don't
feel like you see it but you extract its
meaning anyway then we know that because
it makes you read the next word faster
only if they're related in meaning so
your mind is subliminally primed now
some years ago people used to worry that
advertisers could do this really
cleverly and make you go do stuff the
famous examples historically can they
make you buy popcorn which is now since
it's 48 dollars right it's harder to do
but can they make you buy popcorn you
know the movie theater you know or or
you know can they make you buy a Ford or
a Chevrolet or something like that with
the right subliminal message and that
kinds of stuff
every experiment that's been done to ask
whether subliminal messages of this kind
would make you get up and go do
something like buy a car you know or
change what country you live in or
something it never works okay it never
works okay nobody's ever been able to
show the debt in any experimental
condition which doesn't prevent some
companies from selling these products to
store owners or thinking they're getting
their their sales up right but there's
been never any evidence that these kinds
of subliminal presentations make people
do something big and complicated like
get up and go buy popcorn or choose one
product over another people have never
been able to show that under controlled
experiments but they have been able to
show these kinds of changes in behaviors
at last the moments that last a moment
so what's happening in your brain so
this is the last experiment again
they're presenting these things that you
know in the same place in the computer
monitor all these things to keep fill
your eyes
and then they present a word for either
twenty nine milliseconds that pretended
either very briefly or in full view okay
so here's visible you have because they
remove the confusing visual information
just before and after it here people
don't report seeing it and
scientifically it's really important to
you just say oh people didn't see it but
it's really important in our field to
say we're so convinced and why are we so
convinced because we say was there any
word present because sometimes there's a
word present and sometimes there isn't
just is there a word present if you
could see the word because these things
were a little bit away in time and you
couldn't see it you almost always got it
if it was visible you almost never got
it it was here right you almost never
said there was a word presence um and
and uh could you name it yes if you saw
it like this you couldn't name it if it
was presented brief it was surrounded by
this visual stuff that makes it hard to
see if they give you a memory test for
it if you saw it fully you in full view
you got it if it was hidden like this
you didn't and finally they give you
forced choice they say did you see the
word note or did you see the word coat
choose between the two people are still
a chance fifty-fifty okay so the I mean
feel out there really pushing people to
say really did you see anything do you
know what it wasn't in there completely
a chance they don't remember anything
they can't even tell if a word was there
but we know it influences their mind and
now let me show you what we know of how
it influences your brain so what's shown
here in green are parts of your brain
that respond when a word is shown that
you can see and what's shown here in red
are the parts of your brain that respond
for that subliminally presented word the
word that's presented but you can't tell
that any word was there never mind what
word it was so first you can see there's
a lot more brain response for the
visible than the mast or subliminal word
that makes a lot of sense you see
something you think about it you know it
happened but you can measure what's
happening in the brain it's very small
take this spot here's the response if
it's in full view here's a tiny tiny
tiny tiny response when it's presented
in that minimalist way but it's
measurable and it's present and we know
that it's enough for you to figure out
unconsciously what the meaning of that
word was so then you know we enter with
this paradox which is on the one hand
you know we live in a world where we
only notice a small fraction of what's
around us what we focus our attention to
because we have limited attentional
capacity on the other hand there are
channels of information that sneak into
your mind that probably influence you
only for a few moments in the unattended
ear and the cocktail party you're
actually picking up that conversation
because if they say your name you'll get
it here here's an example of where your
brain is responding to a word you cannot
identify or know that it was presented
and those things can slightly move your
behavior around but not in a science
fiction or marketing dream that they
could make you go do something really
big okay that's never been shown and
people have tried to show that so
attention is really weirder than you
think right you don't notice a lot of
stuff but a few things you don't think
are influencing you are influencing you
here in there all the time thanks very
much